heading south on the m6 in England
Patrick is beginning the long drive to
Ukraine it's a journey he's done many
times to deliver British cars which have
a particular use on the front line
steering is on the right side
and the um
they put a mannequin or a dummy with a
uniform on the left so the Russians
don't take out the driver he aims for
the passenger side and it confuses the
um the Russians
heading across Europe in Convoy with a
team of volunteers this is their
destination
a warehouse in La Viv where the
transformation begins
a small team turn aging pickup trucks
into armored military vehicles within
weeks
here you can see
everywhere for the radio
is vulnerable for the debris so
it's all done under the watchful eye of
Patrick's colleague Ivan Alexi it's
pretty much covered and there is a very
high chance that our soldiers will
survive if they get help from the front
from the back and from the side thank
you
from here they're taken for testing
before long they'll be ready to join
dozens more British cars already in use
on the front line
but Vehicles don't last long out here
and there's a constant need for more
it is just a tiny part of the war effort
but back in the UK the volunteers say
they'll keep making the trip as long as
right hand drive cars are saving
Ukrainian lives Becky Johnson Sky News